gives rise to phenotypic variation and
of course this is important for
understanding
the genetics of diseases as well as
understanding uh genetic variation in
evolution
and here's a reproduction of a classic
photo photograph showing variation in
height
and a set of college students ranging
from from five feet tall to six and a
half feet tall
and the men are in dark and the women
are in white colored clothing
and it's been known for a long time that
height is an extremely heritable trait
so here's a classic plot that was made
by francis galton
um and this uh
that's showing the on the on the x-axis
the average height of parents on the
y-axis the average height of offspring
he shows that they're extremely
correlated and this
gives rise to the notion of regression
um
and in the last so it's been known
since since galton at least that
and probably anecdotally longer that
heights are very heritable trait
um and in the in the last five or uh
eight years or so
there's um been a lot of progress
actually in starting to
dissect the genetic basis of traits like
height
here's a a relatively old plot now from
a paper from 2008 but i think it's
quite a nice plot which shows um
so in this study they identified 20
different loci
where each where for each of these loci
there's a snip that influences height by
um on the order of three to five
millimeters each and so you can classify
the alleles in each individual as
the alleles at each site as being a tall
allele or a short allele
and if you sum up the um the number of
tall alleles that each individual has
you can um predict to some extent what
their height is so so using 20 loci
the range between the the top
predictions and the bottom predictions
about six centimeters
there are now um on the order of several
hundred
height loci that have been identified so
one of the key um questions then is is
to understand a bit more about how
loci like how variants like this
actually affect phenotypes
and um at a very basic level
um of course the the genome uh
you can think of the genome as doing uh
uh
sort of in a very cartoonish way it's
doing two sorts of things
so one kind of thing that genome does is
it encodes
protein coding genes so so part of the
dna sequence here
as serves as a template for making
transcripts this is messenger
rna and then the messenger rna is
translated into protein
and um and so um so
a couple percent of the genome is
devoted to encoding
this genetic information the the protein
coding
gene information and then there's also
um information in the genome that tells
the the cell
when to make each gene on and how much
to make and of course different cell
types are
making so making different proteins and
and so if you think about genetic
variation how it impacts phenotypes
you can think of it doing this
very broadly speaking in two kinds of
ways you can imagine
genetic variants that are affecting the
uh
the sequence that encodes proteins
as well as as well as information that's
changing
gene regulation so it's changing how
much of any given protein you're going
to make and under what circumstances and
so on
and um we we know
uh we've known for a long time quite uh
how to annotate protein coding regions
and protein coding annotations now are
very accurate
um but it's it's big it's turned out to
be a much more challenging problem
to identify regulatory sequences and to
understand
exactly how they work however
it is now becoming clear that
regulatory variants play a really
central role
in complex traits and here's here's one
one example plot there are many many
examples that one could have used here
so the x axis shows position across a
particular region
and then each dot here shows the level
of association between
a snip and and crohn's disease
and down below you can see the locations
of
of genes and so there's a region here
where there are a bunch of snips that
are all statistically associated
with with risk of crohn's disease and
presumably there's one site in here
which is causal
and then a bunch of other variants are
in linkages equilibrium with a causal
site
and and this this variant apparently
lies
outside of any protein coding region and
so we might infer from this that it's
most likely
doing something regulatory but it's
a great deal of work at present to go
from a signal like this
to figuring out which is actually the
causal site
what does it do what's the relevant cell
type which gene is it affecting and so
on
um and it turns out this actually that
that this kind of example is very
typical
so here's a figure from a very nice
paper from joe pickerel which is first
in bio archive
at the end of last year where he
estimates the
the proportion of um
of hits and genomic association studies
that
can be explained by non-synonymous sites
ie sites
that are changing uh protein coding
sequences and you can see for
a bunch of different traits that the
estimates are ranging from something
like two or three percent
up to about 18 or 20 percent
so for all of the traits that he looked
at um the vast majority of
the uh of the um
associated snips are non-coding and so
in general we don't really understand
the mechanisms of these but they
the natural inference is that they're
affecting gene regulation
uh in one way or another
so let's just think about
how this might work so from molecular
biology
but we know quite a lot of the key
players in um
in term in in gene regulation um
there are probably more to be found but
we know many different
uh players um but we still don't really
know how
how to interpret the regulatory
information that's encoded in dna
sequences
so so if you think about the process of
um
of transcription so so here on this plot
this gray bit supposed to represent the
start of a coding region
so so to
to make it to make a protein you have to
start by
transcribing messenger rna
so this rna polymerase is the machine
that does that and then you need to put
together a lot of other machinery
in order to get the the polymerase
properly assembled and get transcription
going
um and um and so the
this this machinery relies on dna
sequences
that encode specific information both
close to the transcription start site as
well as
more distant locations that are often
caught many of these are called
enhancers
and so presumably variants that are
affecting complex
traits but not directly through proteins
in many cases they'll be affecting the
function of these kinds of regulatory
elements
but it's still as i said at this point
it's very difficult to look at the dna
sequence and actually
figure out what what any bit of sequence
does and so this is a problem that
that we and many other groups in the
field have been trying to tackle
we'd like to understand first what are
the primary kinds of mechanisms
by which snips impact gene regulation
and ultimately we like to get much
better
at interpreting non-coding variants that
affect
phenotypes to understand to be able to
figure out for a particular variant
what's the relevant cell type in which
it's affecting regulation
which genes is it likely to be affecting
and so on
so to tackle this that the major
approach that we have taken
is using an approach called
expression quantitative trait locus
mapping so we use this as a tool for
linking genetic variation
to changes in gene regulation so for
those of you not familiar with this let
me just talk you through it quickly
so the the basic idea is that we'll
collect um a particular cell type or
tissue type from
uh from a whole panel of individuals so
in the studies i'll describe it's about
70 individuals
and then we'll use a genome technology
like expression microarrays or rna
sequencing
to measure gene expression uh for
essentially all of the genes in the
genome
and so now for each individual in each
gene
we've got an expression measurement and
then we can ask
whether there are variant snips in the
neighborhood of each gene that are
affecting gene expression
so here in this case perhaps the the
white colored allele
leads to lower expression output than
the green colored allele does here
and so what we'd like to be able to do
is to identify variants like this
that have effects on expression of
nearby genes
and then to understand why they do this
what are the kinds of mechanisms that
cause this
and so i should mention that in this
talk i'm going to be focusing on
uh what are referred to as [ __ ] qtls
this this means
um operationally this means uh
eqtl is where the snip is close to the
target gene
there are also trans eqtls where you've
got to snip somewhere else in the genome
and um and i won't talk about those
because
uh well the mechanisms of transient qtls
are very different from
mechanisms of ccqtls and they're also
more difficult to detect
so let me just give you one example of
an eqtl
this is for the hlac gene
and so these are data from microarrays
each dot shows you the expression level
of hlac
for for a single individual stratified
by genotype here
so you can see that if you've got the cc
genotype you're expressing this gene
at a at a higher average level than
individuals of the aa genotype
and it turns out that this this eqtl is
also associated with hiv-1 progression
through its effect on hlac levels
so we decided to um
to use the um a set of cell lines known
as the hatmap cell lines as a kind of
model system
for studying expression variation and
this is all joint work with
my collaborator at the university of
chicago y'all gilad
so we've been working with a panel of
about 75
uh cell lines from the yoruba population
in nigeria
and um so these are cell lines that were
uh
created by transforming b cells which
are a component of the immune system
into an immortalized resource that you
can grow and originally the idea with
these cell lines was that there'd be a
renewable resource for
dna for the hapmap project and more
recently the thousand genomes project
but uh a number of people including
vivian chung and others realized that
you can actually use these
soul lines as a as a as a resource for
studying
cellular phenotypes and so um
uh and so we we we've taken this
approach where we we take these cell
lines that have been very thoroughly
characterized by the thousand genomes
project
we've got essentially a complete catalog
of genetic variation all of these cell
lines
there's also a lot of um functional
information
uh from from one of these cell lines
that's been collected by the
uh the encode project and um and so
we've been using this as a kind of model
system for understanding these links
between genetic variation
and um and regulation so let me just
give you
uh an example of what one of these
ccqtls looks like
so so these are data from an rna
sequencing experiment that we did
a few years ago the the x-axis here
represents position
along the genome um they uh
the y-axis represents read depth of rna
sequencing data this is essentially a
measure
of the abundance of uh messenger rna
transcript from from this region
and the three lines here um show the
data
stratified according to the genotype but
a particular snip in this region
so if you've got the gg genotype then
you've got this gene turned on if you've
got the aa genotype this gene is
basically turned off
so i'd like to understand more about how
a snip like this or or
a sentence that it's an ld with um
actually acts
so from that study we identified about a
thousand [ __ ] qtls
so um one of the first kinds of
questions you might ask
is um just sort of very basic
description descriptive questions
so um what what are the because what's
the context of the variants that cause
eqtls
and first of all where are they with
respect to the genes that they regulate
now it turns out this isn't a totally um
straightforward question to answer
because of linkage disequilibrium so
linkages equilibrium refers to the
property that snips that are
close together in the genome um
very often uh correlated in their
genotypes and so
uh here's an example where each dot
shows you that the p
value of association between a snippet
in the region of this gene slc-12a7
and an expression of this and you can
see there are a bunch of snips that are
all very significant
presumably one of these snips is a
causal site
and and then the others are simply in
linkages equilibrium with that causal
site
now i would note that here we're using a
thousand genomes data so we've got
a representation of of nearly all of the
common snips in this region or i should
say nearly all of the snips that are in
the
positions that are variable in the
sample so we can be fairly confident
that we've actually got the causal site
here but it's still ambiguous about
which site actually is causal
so so with with this type of data it's
difficult to answer
a seemingly simple question like where
where do causal sites lie around the
target genes
and so to tackle this a few years ago we
developed a
a bayesian hierarchical model and
and the basic idea for this is that
we've we've got analysis at two levels
so there's there's an analysis of the
level of genes
um so so the level of genes we can uh
we can measure the the strength of
association between
snips and gene expression so here these
are
strength associations measured as base
factors
and each snip is going to be annotated
according to
various kinds of uh putative regulatory
annotations or
or distance from genes locations
with respect to genes and so on and then
at the global level
we can use all the genes in the genome
to
ask about they the uh the relative
enrichment
of um of causal sites in in
each uh type of annotation um
and so the idea is that uh we we
parameterize the
prior probability that any given snap
will be cause a causal eqtl
for each gene as a logistic function of
the
um of the annotations that it sits in
with a
prior parameter for each annotation
and then we're going to use all of the
genes in the genome to estimate these
prior parameters
um and so so you can so you can imagine
fitting this as sort of an em
algorithm where you're using all of the
genes in the
all of the qtls in the genome to learn
about these prior parameters
and then these can in turn re-weight the
posterior probabilities
in each region and so you can get a
a maximum likelihood estimate of the the
enrichments for every category
and so one really nice feature of this
type of model is that it gives us a
principled way
of um uh of
estimating the relative enrichments of
the relative importance of different
kinds of
regulatory features in a complicated
model where we've got a bunch of
different features simultaneously
and it's actually quite difficult
to do this in a really principled way
using um
sort of naive methods of just sort of
measuring enrichment
um so just to give you an example of
this
here's a plot uh that shows you that the
basically a his a density plot of the
locations
of eqtls around target genes and so the
top in the top plot
we're just taking the most significant
snip for
each um for each eqtl
so basically can if there's a snip
that's um
that's significant above some threshold
then we we plot the uh the location of
the most significant snip for that gene
um so this this shows you the upstream
region for each gene
the black uh bit shows you the the
transcript
and the right hand side shows you the
downstream region
and this is the our estimated density
that we get from the hierarchical model
and you can see that this
um this strongly down weights the these
long range effects
and and it concludes that this peak of
um
of eqtls and the vicinity of the
transcription start site
is much stronger yes um what's on the
left hand side what's an eqtm uh yes
apologies um
so uh eqtn
here the um the n is referring to
nucleotides so this is an
estimate of the density of causal sites
so
um uh sorry i i skipped that but
so basically the distinction is that
we've in terminology
is that an eqtl is a location where
there's we think that there's a variance
associated with
expression but it may be ambiguous which
is the causal site
and then the eqtn is our estimate of
which site is causal
yeah thank you for the question um so
anyway so uh some features that you see
from this are
first of all there's a very strong
concentration of eqtls
around or eqtns around transcription
start sites which makes a
lot of sense because a lot of the
regulatory machinery is there
there's generally uh enrichment
throughout the transcribed region so
um it seems like the transcribed region
sort of sets up a domain of regulations
so for very long
for very long genes it's more likely
that you've got regulatory
uh regions that are at a distance
downstream from the transcription start
site than in short read than in short
genes
um and also we find that there are
relatively few
really long range eqtls although
they do exist but they're a small
minority of all eqtls
okay so
um so to summarize quite a lot of uh
other work that we've done
um we we found that uh most eqtls lie
inside or near to their target genes
we also find that they're enriched in
active chromatin regions and
transcription factor binding motifs um
but but in some ways uh just doing
computational analysis of the uh
of the eqtls was a bit unsatisfying
because it we found it was really hard
to make sense of
the vast majority of eqtls and so the
next question was how to dig deeper into
these
mechanisms and so um to tackle this
problem
uh we thought about
the mechanisms of eqtls in the following
way so so when you have an eqtl
basically what you
observe is an association between a snip
and the steady state levels of mature
mrna
in the cell so what are the kinds of
processes that
that determine these steady state levels
well you've got
sort of a life cycle of mrna that starts
with
epigenetic modifications and priming the
chromatin
through transcription processing of the
mr
of the pre-mrna and also at the end of
the life of mrna
there are processes like rna decay and
rna degradation that are removing mrna
from the system
so the uh the amount of mrna at steady
state represents a balance between
these these kinds of processes and and
removal of mrna from the system
um i'm not going to talk about it today
um
but of course there are also very
important steps in gene regulation
uh at the stages of translation and and
the controls of mature protein levels
and we're starting to do a bunch of work
in this area as well which
which shows that actually there is a lot
of
cis acting variation affecting uh
translation
and perhaps mature protein levels as
well um but we
we're not as far along and that work we
don't understand that as well
um so to make sense of so so to learn
more about these eqtl snips
our idea was that we can take um a
variety of different genome-wide assays
that have been developed in the last few
years for querying each of these
different stages
of gene regulation and then if an eqtl
acts through uh altering any one of
these features so for example
by by altering histone marks or
chromatin accessibility then this eqtl
snip
should also be a qtl for these genomic
assays
and then you would see um that the uh
there's an effect that gets carried on
through all the stages of the mrna life
cycle
from that point onwards and so um today
i'm going to tell you just about work
that we've done at this first step of
chromatin priming because we think this
is a particularly important stage
at which eqtls are
most often acting so i'm going to start
with telling you a little bit about work
that we've done with dna s1
and so dna s1 is is an enzyme
that's been been used for a long time
since the 70s
as a tool for identifying regions of
active chromatin
so so if you think about the dna in the
cell most of the dna
is wrapped up around nucleosomes and so
it's tightly packaged it's relatively
inaccessible
to gene regulation so an important step
of gene regulation is is that the dna is
opening up nucleosomes are
getting ejected and um transcription
factors are coming in
and binding the the dna and enacting
um programs of gene regulation
and so when you have active gene
regulation usually
um you you get regions of uh
regions where the dna is relatively
honor where the dna is relatively open
and unprotected by proteins like
nucleosomes and so dna s1 is an enzyme
that can come in and clip the dna
sequence
in these open regions and so basically
the assay is that you treat the cells of
this dna s1
enzyme you get these these cut points
and then you take the
you take the fragments in sequence from
the cut points on next generation
sequencer
and you you get a profile of basically
the the sensitivity
of each location the genome to cutting
by dna's one
and here's an example um of what the dna
is one profile looks like
um in average around the binding site of
a particular transcription factor called
nrsf
so so nrsf has a binding site of about
20 base pairs where it's sitting on the
dna sequence
and and the actual location where nrsf
is sitting
protects it uh protects the dna
from cutting by dna s1 but then off on
the left and the right
you've got high rates of of cutting
because the the
dna is relatively open and then as you
go further off in either direction to
scale there's about 50
base pairs you're moving into
nucleosomal regions where the dna is
protected
so the idea is that dna's one gives us a
relatively generic assay
of rig of active regulatory regions
and we've also done quite a bit of work
on using this kind of signal
to actually identify transcription
factor binding sites
more generally for a very large number
of transcription factors
um i should mention that other groups
like greg crawford's group and john
stametoyan officers
lab have also done a lot of work with
with dna s1
and also developing methods in this area
so the idea that we had was that um
since dna s1 is providing this
information about
um active chromatin for a
large variety of types of active
chromatin
we had the idea that by looking at
variation in dna swan sensitivity across
individuals
would be able to identify snips that are
affecting
this early stage of gene regulation and
so we did dna s1 sequencing
in in 70 europa soul wines um which was
uh quite a challenging experiment which
was led by
uh athena pai who was a a wonderful
graduate student in
gilad's lab um so okay so the basic idea
here
then is that we've got 70 individuals uh
we
we get uh dna swan sequencing data for
each individual so these are short reads
map them onto the genome
identify regions that are sensitive to
dna's one
cleavage in at least a subset of the
individuals so these are often referred
to as
dna s1 hypersensitive sites and then
we look for genetic variants that are
associated with sensitivity here
so perhaps the pink allele here is
associated with higher sensitivity
and so we refer to these as dsqtls so
dna s1 sensitivity qtls
and so when we did this experiment we
found that actually there's a tremendous
amount of variation in the genome
in dna1 sensitivity so we identified
more than 8
000 dsqtls across the genome and
here are what the qq plots look like
so so for this we're taking
two different window sizes around each
dna's hypersensitive site
so so the green dots are taking a 2kb
region window centered on each
hypersensitive site and then testing
every snip in that window
for association with the hypersensitive
site um
that the black dots are for a 40 kb wide
window
and and you get the sense from this
these qq plots that
first of all there's a tremendous amount
of dsqtl variation
and then secondly that most of the
regulation of dsqtls is
over very short distances um and i won't
show you the hierarchical model results
but they're very consistent with this
uh intuitive notion you're getting from
this um
so let me just show you an example of
what these things look like so this is a
about a 200 base pair region and the
three lines here show you the
dna sensitivity of this region
stratified by the genotype at a snip
that's right in the center of the region
so i feel so if you've got the the cc
genotype
then this the sensitivity the
sensitivity of this region's about
tenfold the genome-wide average
if you've got the tt genotype then this
region's basically closed off so the
sensitivity here looks like
like the background signal um it turns
out that this
particular dsqtl seems to be due to
disruption of a
binding site of a transcription factor
called nf kappa b
so there's a match to the the nf kappa b
motif at this particular location
and the um the c allele here matches the
um the preferred binding site for nf
kappa b
the t completely wipes out that binding
site
and so our inference is that if you uh
if you destroy that binding site the nf
kappa b
can't get in here and so then the whole
region gets covered over in nucleosomes
and it becomes insensitive to dna s1
um we we can get some evidence for the
presence of nf kappa b
from independent data from mike snyder's
lab so there's a chip seek data for nf
kappa b
um also in lymphoblastic cell lines and
you can see that there's a
peak of nf kappa b binding uh here for
the cc genotype
but there's no nf kappa b binding in tt
individuals
so the next kind of question is do these
dsq tails that have identified affect
gene expression
and happily the answer is they do
so here's one example here's a dsqtl
so there's a snip in the middle of this
sensitive region it's a couple hundred
base pairs wide
so the aa genotypes relatively sensitive
the gg genotype is relatively
insensitive
and this this gene
this hypersensitive site um is in the
neighborhood of this gene here
and you can see that the the sensitive
um genotype for this
dhs located here produces relatively
high gene expression
the um the gg genotype has this gene
virtually turned off
um and and we find this is a very common
pattern
so we estimate that
um using our current data about 55
percent of eqtls
are associated with changes in dna s1
sensitivity
and there are some reasons why there are
there are some dsqtls that we miss so
the actual answer may even be higher
than this um
so this seems to be one fundamental
mechanism by which dsqtls are generated
yes
they always show these almost perfect
patterns um
you mean that the uh the heterozygote is
intermediate um
yes so so generally we think that these
act
um the the two chromosome copies act
independently through a
sort of a cis acting mechanism and so um
uh yeah so we yes
so so as far as so i don't think we've
found any good examples of
of departures from additivity um uh
i mean there may be something we haven't
found yet
um so anyway so here's a qq plot
where what we take what we're doing here
is we're taking dsqtls
and then we're asking whether they're
associated with expression of nearby
genes
and and you can see there's a tremendous
amount of signal here
so it's a two-sided qq plot because you
can imagine
on the right hand side you can have an
increase in dna that the allele
increases dna s1 sensitivity
is associated with increases in
expression and on the left hand side
you can have increases in sensitivity go
along with decreased expression
so you can see that there are more of
these activating dsqtls and there are
repressing dsqtls
and this is about a factor of two to one
um you can also see
that for dsqtls that are very close to
the transcription start site
quite a large fraction of these are
associated with
changes in expression although there are
also longer range
effects so we next wanted to
understand a bit more about how disk qts
are changing chromatin function
and so to do this we collected
additional data
on a variety of different assays that
are querying different aspects
of gene regulation so we looked at
nucleosome positioning
a bunch of histone marks rna polymerase
2 dna methylation
and what we find is that these dsqtl
snips
are typically driving very coordinated
changes in a whole suite of different
aspects of chromatin so so these
different aspects of chromatin are
really co-varying together
and individual snips are able to
toggle the levels of all of these things
simultaneously
so here's one example where so the
different tracks here
are showing the results of different
assays
and the different colors here show you
the read depths segregated by
genotype so the dark blue is a a um
this and there's a g and gg and so you
can see that the
um the aa individuals have got high dna
s1 sensitivity
they've got high rna polymerase and
they've got high marking by
two different histone marks that are
associated with active chromatin
and finally they've got high rna seq
levels so this shows you expression of
the first exon of this gene
and so you can see in this particular
example that that one sniff is is
producing very coordinated changes and
and every basically everything that we
looked at
um and this is a relatively uh clean
example
um but but in general we estimate that
the correlations between these different
um molecular factors
are very high we also find
the data here a bit noisy but we find
that there's generally quite a strong
correlation between
dna s1 sensitivity on the x-axis and
transcription factor binding
data from from encode the data are noisy
here because we're only using one
individual
and there's not very good read depth
secondly we find that dna s1
sensitivities associated with
systematic changes in nucleosome
positioning around the
affected sites so this shows the
average density of nucleosomes um
centered on
dna s1qtls and
and here that the different lines are
averaging
the the high heterozygote and low dna s1
genotypes
so you can see that they the genotypes
that are associated with high dns 1
sensitivity
i showed you they're also associated
with high transcription factor occupancy
they tend to have low nucleosome
occupancy at the center of the dsqtl
and then very strong nucleosome
positioning compared to the other
genotypes
now one thing i would note here is that
um
even in these um active regulatory
regions
there's still um substantial nucleosome
occupancy and the way to think about
this
is that all of these assays that we do
are on a population of cells
and so at any given time an active
regulatory region
we believe is only actually active
in in a modest fraction of the cells uh
in the population
and it's probably a dynamic process
although
it's still very difficult to measure the
dynamics
and i'll come back to this later but
what we think is that
these dsqtls are probably shifting
the fraction of cells that are active in
any given region
from let's say uh 30 to 20 percent they
tend not to be binary changes
between on and off states
we also find that there are um sites
that
uh that uh create long distance changes
in in chromatin um so so these would be
so examples of these will be the dsqtls
that are affecting um
expression at a distant promoters
so here's here's one example so these
are tracks for um
for a bunch of different uh chromatin
features
here's an enhancer region there's a snip
in this enhance that affects dna s1
sensitivity
and histone marking here it also affects
the
the function of this promoter which is
about 25 kilobases away
and
and this this is quite a common kind of
feature that you have long range effects
um on chromatin from from one site to a
distant promoter
so in the last part of the talk i just
want to say a little bit
about i'm trying to understand the the
precise
sequence features that are being
impacted by these dsqtls
and so i think that one really nice um
aspect of studying
uh genetic variation gene regulation is
that we can start to get
the causal pathways between uh between
dna sequence
and gene regulation so um so one real
challenge in the genomics field
is that we can measure many many
different things and we find that
that you get strong correlations between
many different features that you measure
but it's generally been quite difficult
to uh figure out what things
uh are causally upstream of of what
so for example it's been shown that
histone marks um
are highly correlated with one another
and also are able to predict
um transcription factor binding and
and active enhancers and promoters and
so on and so
the um and so a lot of the language in
the field has suggested that perhaps
these
these histone marks are causally
upstream of the function
of the of the enhancers um but it's
difficult to tell
from the genomic data alone what's
what's the order of um
of the mechanism um but of course we
know that
uh dna sequence variation is um
is is extremely stable so the genotype
is extremely stable
so that must be causally upstream of
anything of any of the genomic assays
that we measure
so um so the punchline is going to be
that we find in many cases
these chromatin qtls act by disrupting
transcription factor binding sites
and these these changes in transcription
factor binding
can play causal roles in altering
everything else that we've measured so
let me just
talk you through the logic of this um
and in a cartoon
so so here let's suppose that we we
focus on a particular transcription
factor
like let's say pu1 and we can identify
all of the um so we've got
uh estimates of where uh pu1 is binding
across the genome
and then we can identify all of the
snips that sit
in pu1 binding motifs and now
for each of those cases where we've got
a snip in a pu1 binding site
we can classify the two alleles
according to which allele
is predicted to have better pu1 binding
and which is predicted to have worse pu1
binding so here that the x is supposed
to indicate the allele
that has uh that is predicted to have
worse pu1 binding
and now we can ask whether the direction
of effect here on the transcription
factor
is associated with um with aggregate
changes
in in any of the other kinds of features
that we've measured
um so under the null hypothesis we might
expect if we look
for example at histone marking in the
neighborhood of these transcription
factors
if if binding of the transcription
factor
is is not causally is not causal of
histone marking
then we should see that if there's any
change at all in
histone marking across genotypes the
direction should be random
so on average there should be zero
effect on
on on histone marking
conversely if if binding of the
transcription factor
causes for example an increase in in
marking
uh by a code active histone mark then we
should see on average that the allele
that is predicted of better binding
should be associated with increases in
histone marking
and and in fact we see this very
systematically
so here are the data for pu1
these show you that the fitted
regression lines for
um for a bunch of the different uh for
different things that we measured so let
me just explain this the x-axis here
takes the two alleles um in a snip
and it measures the the difference in
predicted transcription factor binding
um between the genome reference allele
and the old terms allele so
so the right hand side means that the um
the reference allele has better binding
than the old better predicted binding
than the alternate allele of the snip
and then the y
axis shows that the mean difference in
chip seek read depth
in heterozygotes and so what you can see
is that there are
all of these factors here that are that
are associated with active chromatin
are systematically increasing when
uh uh on the allele that we predict
should have better binding
for pu1 and conversely k27
trimethylation which is a
a mark that's associated with with
repression of chromatin
has the reverse direction um
uh more globally when we look across all
transcription factors
we find that that in aggregate there's
an effect that
globally all of the transcription
factors are associated with
um with uh increased uh increases in all
of the active histone marks and
paul two and here are a bunch of uh
of the particular transcription factors
that are most significant
um there's one exception that we
identified in the data
uh which is nrsf and nrsf is a
well-known repressive
factor um it's associated with the
polycom-repressive complex
and polycom-repressive complex is
important for laying down
this k-27 trimethylation and you can see
this has got a very different pattern
from all of the other transcription
factors that
for which we found signals in these data
so just to summarize this last part of
the talk
what we think is that most of the
regulatory regions
have got competition between the these
active
and inactive states these inactive
active and active chromatin
configurations
and and so there'll be that there's
active configuration where there's
transcription factor binding
and high dna s1 sensitivity and strong
nucleosome positioning and histone
marking and so on
and then this inactive state where the
regions are basically closed down
and we we don't have direct measurements
of this but my guess is that this is
probably
a relatively dynamic process where the
chromosomes are flipping between the two
states
and then the idea is that if you've got
snips that
weaken transcription factor binding then
that will tend to
push the system in in this direction
and as i said most of the
snips that are common variation in the
population which are the things that we
can actually
detect as qtls tend to have relatively
weak effects
so they'll they presumably weaken the
ability of a tf to bind in a particular
location
and that will tend to shift the
equilibrium in this direction but only
in a quantitative way
and then a fraction of these
dsqls then go on and affect gene
expression
okay so um just to summarize
um so we find that these th
that a major set of of says eqtls act
through these changes in chromatin
um that are sort of very highly
coordinated changes in
multiple aspects of chromatin in in a
quantitative way
and i didn't have time to talk about
this today but um we've got some new
data on
studying um qtls and effect translation
and steady state protein levels
and i think this is going to be a very
interesting story as well so
this is something that the mrna qtl
can't tell us about it so let me just
thank the the key people have been
involved in this work
um so so joav is my uh
experimental collaborator in chicago
matthew stevens has been involved with
the
quite a lot of the statistical work um
athena is a really
key experimental person in york's lab
who helped to spearhead a lot of the
early
work that we did in this area
jack and roger led the
the dna s1 work
and graham and bryce did all of the
histone work
and alexis is uh involved in the
uh the project now to sort of put
together all the things that we've we've
measured so far as well as the
uh the protein um uh the protein stuff i
alluded to
so i'll end there
any questions for them
yes
do you mean between populations um
uh so i didn't talk about it um so
there's
so we uh there so there's been some work
on that although we haven't contributed
much of it so
um there's so for eqtls
there are
there's some debate about how much uh uh
how much specific
whether there are good examples of
population specific eqtls
um so there's sort of the trivial case
where you've got a a snip that's an eqtl
that's not segregating in different
populations but it's not
really clear whether there are
interesting population specific
utls where you have uh a variant that's
segregating in two populations but
there's only an eqtl and one of them
um i don't think there are good examples
of that that
people believe um uh
yeah there's been a bit of work on so
mike snyder's lab has done some of this
work on uh population specific variation
in
in chromatin um and and i think again
most
probably the vast majority of that is
driven by differences in snip allele
frequencies but
you know it's certainly hunter present
shown
quite strong differences between yoruba
and european
on the continent that's the dna
methylation right yeah yes
yes yeah thank you yeah
yeah you've um
looked at sort of sniffs affecting me
yes yes have you looked at higher
moments like variance for example i mean
you need bigger
like larger sample sizes for that um do
you think it would be interesting to
look at variance in
gene expression good question uh the
question is about variance in gene
expression
um so we we haven't done any of that
um i'm just trying to think i think
there's been some eqtl work on variants
um
yeah so we haven't done it i think that
uh i mean for studying variants you have
to be a little bit careful
in in the measurements so you can just
sort of in how you do the scaling
um one thing i've been kind of
interested in is i think i think
that that type of experiment is
difficult to interpret but i think the
one context where
you know where it could be interesting
actually would be to do this level of
single cell rna sequencing so
uh you know maybe more interpretable in
that context so
so you could imagine that there may
there may be variants that are
that are not changing the mean level but
they're changing the fraction of cells
that are
expressing a particular gene at a
substantial level um
yeah so we haven't done much in that
notion i think it's essentially
interesting yes uh presumably when
one gets around to working in the
transacting factors we'll get at some of
this issue
off of variance and gene expression in a
specific
the variance that you see in the
expression of the cis acting
in your cis acting analysis is can
presumably be attributed
if one knew the transacting factor
yes yeah yes i'm sure that that's true
um
yeah so that'll be variance as i'm like
presumably mostly uncorrelated with
genotype at the
cis locus but the question about the
variance in the cis acting expression
yeah
some of that is very instant
environmental but a lot of it is going
to be actually transaction
agreed yes so so alcus price has
estimated that
um i can't remember that i think maybe
you know
a bit more than half of the total
variance in gene expressions due to
transacting
um effects i mean i think that you know
it's probably the case that the most
transacting effects
um you know start as a cis-acting change
um in one location in the genome that
you know that then has transacting
effects elsewhere so
you know i think it you know even though
even though transacting
even though trans effects are
responsible for a lot of the genetic
variants
you know you you can uh you know i think
the key to understanding this still
starts from
from sets but i mean i agree with your
comment
yeah just following up on that there was
alcusa's paper
was really interesting in that there was
two measurements of this one of uh which
was what proportion of the variance of
the expression was transacting
um one of them was in blood and the
other was in uh cell culture and it was
a different proportion and i think there
was like a
thought that the heterogeneity of the
tissue type actually affected this so if
you're in a heterogeneous tissue type
like blood
um i think more will be transacting
because it's uh
uh because because you're actually
seeing many different tissue types and
you're actually averaging all those
cysts in
yeah um there's some issue like this so
it's hard to yeah
agree here so i think the one part of
his result was that there's
um there's relatively little sharing of
trans
the transheritability between between
the cell types and so
that's sort of consistent with the idea
that you get reduced
trans heritability in the mixed cell
type yeah
um yeah i think it's a great paper
actually
okay so let's thanks chinatown